Let's say I have a path in the xy plane, that essentially
is the unit circle.
This is my y-axis, this is my x-axis, and our path
becomes the unit circle.
And we are going to do it this way.
We're going to turn it clockwise.
I think you understand the idea.
And the comparison is therefore that of the unity circle.
So the equation is x squared plus y is squared
equal to 1; has a radius of 1 unit circle.
And as far as we are concerned it is about the line integral
about this curve c.
It is a closed curve c.
Actually it goes in the direction of 2y dx minus 3x dy.
So, we are inclined to Green's statement
to use and why not?
Let's try.
This is our path.
So the statement of Green tells us that the integral of a curve
f times dr over a path where f equals-- let me have it
what nicer writing.
Where f of x, y is equal to P of x, yi plus Q of x, y j.
That this integral is equal to the double integral of the
area-- This is the area that it is about
in this example.
over the area of ​​the portion of Q with respect to x
minus the portion of P with respect to y.
All that times dA, the differential of the surface.
And of course, the area is what I just showed you.
Maybe you remember-- there is one
something small here, whatever you like it
would give the wrong answer.
In the last video we said that Green's statement applies when
we go counterclockwise.
See it with a little thing on the integral
counterclockwise.
In our example, the curve goes clockwise.
the area is on our right.
Green's position applies if the area is on our left.
So in this situation if the region is to our right and
we are going-- so this is counterclockwise.
So in our example, where we go clockwise, the area is
on our right, Green's position becomes
the negative of this.
So in our example, we need the integral of c - en
we go clockwise.
So that's how I draw it. Van f times dr. This is
equal to the double integral of the area.
You can swap this-- the part of P relating to
to y minus the portion of Q with respect to x da.
So let's do that.
This becomes equal to, in this example, the
integral of the area-- let's leave it now
keep abstract
We could set limits, but let's
keep the area abstract.
And what's the part of P regarding-- let's remember,
this here is our-- I think we can assume now
that if we take dr f times, we get this.
The dr gives these parts.
The f gives these two parts.
So this is P of x, y.
And then this is Q of x, y.
And we saw it.
I don't always want it
take product.
I think you can see that this is the internal product
of two vectors.
This is the x component of f, y component of f.
This is the x component of dr, y component of dr. So let
we take the part of P with respect to y.
We take the derivative of this with respect to y, you get 2.
the Derivative of 2y is just 2.
So you get 2, and then, minus the derivative of
Q with respect to x.
The derivative of this with regard to x is -3.
So we get -3, and all that times da.
And this is equal to the integral of the area.
What is this, it is 2 min -3?
That is the same as 2 plus 3.
So it's the integral of the 5dA region.
5 is a constant, so we take it from the integral.
So it becomes a fairly simple problem in the end.
So this is equal to 5 times the double integral
of the area R dA.
What is this now?
What is this here?
It seems very abstract, but we can solve this.
It is only the surface of the area.
That is what the double integral stands for.
You just take all the small DAs.
This is a dA, this is a dA.
You count the infinite amount of small
dAs in the area together.
Well, what is the surface of this unit circle?
This involves a bit of third-class knowledge.
rather than that maybe-- pre-algebra or first year
geometry.
Surface area is equal to pi r squared.
what is our radius?
Unity circle, so our radius is 1.
Length is 1.
So the surface here is pi.
so this little thing here, that whole thing is
just equal to pi.
so the answer to our line integral is 5 pi, what
quite a simple one.
I mean, we would have the trouble of setting up a double
may have taken integrally, where we take the primitive with regard to
write y first and write y is equal to the negative square root of 1
min x squared y equals the positive square root.
x ranges from minus 1 to 1.
But that really takes a beard and we don't feel like it.
And we just have to realize, no, this is just the surface.
And I challenge you
solve the same in its entirety without using Green's theorem.
You know, after generating a parameterization of these
curve, in that direction, taking the distractions
from x from t and from y from t.
Multiplying the appropriate and then the primitive taking--
A huge detour so compared to using
Green's statement to get 5 pi.
And remember, the reason it wasn't a -5 pi here,
is because we go clockwise.
If we went counterclockwise
we could have used the normal position of Green.
And we would have received -5 pi.
Anyway, I hope you found this useful.